Hello JSConf! How are you?! Yes.
Thank you.
I'm Dominikus Baur and as you might of noticed
I suffer from an all too common problem in
the tech world, which is yet another bearded
dude.
And, here's my totally scientific analysis
of the JSConf speake speaker profile pictures
on the web site.
As you can see, I'm not alone, there are so
many of us, we should probably form a support
group or something or just shave those damn
things off, I don't know.
So, any ways what does this bearded guy do?
I'm based in Munich, Germany and I work as
a data visualization freelancer, here are
some of the projects that I did in the recent
time I had a bat better life index for OECD,
I did sell if I city, which is an analysis
of the Selfie phenomenon, and also visits
here which is the visualization for personal
travels.
And you can find them all on my web site,
so check them out.
They're of course web‑based.
All right, so let's start, I guess most of
you know data visualization, otherwise you
wouldn't be here.
The basic idea is to turn complex data sets
into visually representations and if they're
done right then you can easily spot patterns
and understand the underlying data.
And, this year, for example, is a pretty famous
and old one, and it depicts Napoleons march
to Moscow.
In this graphic you can see the course that
the army took, you can see it's shrinking
size, so people are dying there.
And you can also see the temperature down
at the bottom which might give you a clue
why the army was shrinking.
So you have lots and lots of information in
an easily digestible format you can argue
that it's somewhat beautiful.
So, that makes data V I S for p perfect tool
for portable devices think of all the data
you're producing or have to work with while
on the go, and visualizations spares you from
working with the raw numbers and gives you
a quick overview to find out what's important.
And with displays becoming even smaller now,
maybe even watch sized, it can quickly show
you what's relevant or interesting to you
without forcing you to look at a spread sheet.
Okay, so how do we go about building these
things? Of course, there's the native approach,
but, as you all know that's a real pain to
do it like that, so you have to support IOS
of coursing you also have to support Andriod
and they're completely different, once you
actually visit the zoo and try to do something
for windows phone or Blackberry or whatever
they are all called, you're in a complete
mess and porting code isn't easily possible.
So what better way to solve this problem than
going to the web.
So, the web has come so far in the past years
that it's viable to develop full blown applications
even for mobile devices, especially news organizations
are very keen to create visualizations and
attractive visualizations that work across
devices, of course, so here's a couple of
examples from the New York times who are doing
an amazing job out there, but there are other
teams like the Guardian Washington Post and
so on that are also creating really cool stuff.
Okay, so, what I'll try today is I'll try
to give you a quick crash course of developing
data visualizations for mobile devices in
20 minutes or less.
First, I'll give you a quick overview, I'll
talk a little bit about responsive web design
and how that already gets us halfway to our
target, I would say.
But, it's also interesting to pursue mobile
first approach to focus on the strengths that
you actually get from having a portable device,
that's also touch controlled, which lets you
do much more interesting stuff.
And finally, of course, the big issue, I would
say in this whole topic is interray action,
so how do you best support an interaction
on those tiny portable screens.
If you need more inspirations for this topic,
here's two web sites that can give you that,
so mobileV.is and the other one is mobileinfov
Uzi.com, and both just collections of mobile
visualizations, you can look at those, they're
ever growing and there's really great stuff
there.
Okay.
Of what are the main differences between desktop
and mobile? So first, the obvious one, interaction
happens via touch instead of a mouse, so,
we no longer have this one single minuscule
cursor, but we have potentially multiple fingers
that are overlapping everything on your screen
and just creating a mess, and we have very
specific results of that, for example, we're
losing hovering, we're getting something else
like hovering, I'll talk about that in a minute.
There's really a huge difference between that,
and then, second of course, we have different
screen sizes and formats, so with a laptop,
or a desktop, we usually have relatively low
Res, large screens, 16 by 10 or 16 by 9 aspect
ratio in landscape and on mobile devises you
have your high resolution, very, very small
portrait oriented screens.
And, this of course changes how you go about
information layout, density, things like that.
All right, if you want to develop data Vis
for the web, I remember mend one library that
you might have heard about today, already‑‑
I'll recommend one library you might have
heard about today already, we had this fantastic
talk before where we saw there's a huge, another
zoo out there with all of those various types
of charting libraries that let you do crazy
things.
All in different ways, but really, D3 is kind
of the lowest common denominator, so people
that are doing data V I S know of it.
So who here has heard of it? Who has used
it? Cool.
So, it really is pretty common.
It's mostly being developed by one guy, Mike
post dock working at the New York times, I'm
not sure if that gives them an unfair advantage,
yeah, who knows, Mike is doing an amazing
job, he's producing lots and lots of example
for 3 D if you go to BL.ocks.org, you can
find hundreds and hundreds of things with
really really amazing stuff in there, D3 has
a very, very active community, and still being
developed and hasn't been abandoned two years
ago or something like that.
What's really great about those examples here,
usually they work directly on mobile, so if
you open up this page on your smartphone,
for example and try one of these, it usually
just works because the interaction issue isn't
one for D3, so if you want to go from mouse
to touch, usually you only have to change
your vent handlers a bit, so usually on a
desktop you would write something like that,
on mouse down, do something.
And for touch, those events, those vent names
change to touch star, touch move, touch end
instead of the mouse equivalents, of course,
those events can appear multiple times because
you have multiple fingers, then you can keep
track of those fingers and do pinching and
stuff.
The nice thing is that most of the three automatically
does that, so you have certain behaviors that
automatically support pinching for example
so interaction really spent an issue, what's
anker shoe is screen size.
3 D leaves all the scaling to the developer,
pretty much.
And that means, of course, that your visualization
then becomes really tiny on a small screen,
so those are screen shots from Bl.ocks.org,
as they would appear on your smartphone, imagine
that thing a little bit smaller, and especially
with like, the tree map on the right here,
you can really read anything or do anything
with it.
So scaling is an issue.
And, of course, what codew we do when we want
to have our web sites scale, right? We go
to responsive web design, which is fantastic,
so basically, you want to have a page that
adjusts to the size of your view port, and,
we can apply those same principles that we
get in responsive web design to visualizations,
of course, so you grab your favorite responsive
web design framework like foundation or bootstrap
or whatever, then your chart just becomes
one of those boxes in your grid, and you give
it a fixed width and then it's just based
on the device's screen size so that's really
useful I'll show you an example from my own
work where we use that.
So the OCED willing been project was something
that I did with Moritz Stefaner, you might
know OECD, it's a big organization that collects
data on well‑being and how people feel worldwide.
And this project here regional well being
focuses on certain regions on the globe so
you can check out how well people are doing
in certain aspects so we have things like
safety, the job market, education and so on.
And they asked us to create a visualization
that lets people easily explore this data,
our idea is to focus on a certain region and
then let people explore from there, and what
better region for that than the one where
people actually level at the moment, so this
page starts with your home region, then you
get this nice visualization that shows the
various aspects of well being.
You get a list of similar regions to your
own which sometimes is very surprising, and
then down at the bottom of the page you get
an overview of those of quality factors and
details so you can compare, for example, safety
to other regions in your country and so on.
Okay, so you can just Bruce that, you can
just jump from region to region, adds we didn't
have the budget to create three different
web sites for three different form factors
we made the whole thing responsive, and if
you're trying it on your tablet or your smartphone
even you might see that it should just work.
And hear's kind of the underlying magic so
all of those pink boxes are our grid elements
in bootstrap, and, yeah, by just putting those
visualizations into those boxes you actually
get the whole responsiveness for free.
And, depending on your screen size, of course,
the layout changes some elements become bigger
on smartphones for example, and as you can
see, like those three detail views in a row
become two and then one on a smartphone, so
it actually works pretty well.
But, of course, that's not everything, there
are those little details that you learn on
the go, on the job.
And I'll talk about those a bit.
So one thing is drawing a visualization is
usually quite heavy on the CPU and the battery
and so on.
And you don't want to dill your browser tab
just because you decide that you want to redraw
your visualization every time the user adjusts
the window size by one fix el.
So that's when something like debounce for
example or throttle comes in really handy,
I usually use the underscore version, but
there are, of course other implementations
out there.
The basic ideas behind those debouncers is
that you give it a function, in our case,
render, and this function, is at most, called
every resize, refresh, rate, if you set that
to 300 milliseconds then it's only drawn every
third of a second and not like hundreds of
times per second.
Which is quite useful and you might also see
that if you actually try it on your laptop
and adjust the size of the window you see
that the visualization takes a bit to be redraw,
but at least that keeps us from crashing the
browser window, which is nice.
Of all right, another thing are meta view
ports, so that's something you want to set
on mobile devices.
It's just in the header of your HTML, and
there's this meta tag called view port.
And you can define certain things how mobile
Safari or mobile Chrome displays your web
site.
You can say for example width equals the vice
width the web site is initially as big as
your screen, from the width.
And you also want to set the initial scale
to one, so it's zoomed to one hundred percent.
Sometimes it might be useful to say something
like user scalable equals no, which means
that people can't enlarge your page by pinching.
Depends on the application if you want to
did that.
One last thing when you come to responsive
visualizations are SVGU view port, most are
build in SVG, I guess all the 3 D examples
use SVG, usually.
And what's nice about SVG is that as the names
scalable vector graphics implies, it's actually
a vector graphic so it can easily be scaled
and you can control that using CSS.
So with the view box, attribute here you can
define your own virtual coordinate system
within the SVG, so here the coordinate system
goes from zero zero to 500 by 250.
And, everything that you draw within the SVG
is then scaled according to this coordinate
system.
And what you also want to do is you want to
define that the aspect ratio of your virtual
coordinate system stays the same, and that's
what the second attribute does, preserve aspect
ratio.
There's actually two parameters, the second
one meet means your SVG is always scaled so
that it's everything is visible and nothing
is cut off.
And, the first one, the XMidYMin thing, means
your SVG view port should be centered on the
horizontal access and should be aligned with
the minimum on the Y access.
So it looks like this.
So if the SVG actually fits into your window,
everything is fine.
And here it's a bit different, here is where
you actually get horizontally centered box.
Which is your SVG.
And, it's also kind of ary site in web development,
so you get that for free if you set those
attributes.
Okay, but let's dive a little bit more into
details, when it comes to mobile data visualization.
What happens when you actually approach this
whole problem from a mobile first design perspective.
And see what comes up.
So, first of all, usually, the person that
uses your visualization on the smartphone
is like this woman here.
So, they're in the middle of something, they're
not in the mid for any of your fancy sha Nan
gans, they want the data as wick quickly as
possible.
So, I would say always when it comes to mobile
interaction design, just going to let that
loop.
When it comes to mobile interaction design,
think about what's the task of the person
that's using your App or visualization or
whatever, and try to support that as well
as possible.
And what's rally helpful with designing something
like that is, sorry, I have to take your picture
away now, guys.
What's rally helpful is that you can get certain
aspects of the concepts using the new HTML
5 APIs, when is Geo location, who's used that
already if yes, awesome, this one's really
great, it basically gives you the user's current
position, global position in this little amount
of code, so you just call get current position,
you give it a call back and hopefully you
get some latitude and longitude.
So we use that as well in the regional well
being project, so if you open it up on your
smartphone our your browser then you get something
like this pop up here that asks you if the
web site is allowed to use the current location.
So you can also see that it's actually much
more privacy conscious than server base solutions
that just do it based on your I P address
without asking you.
Once you set that up, you get the visualization
starts on your home region or the region that
you're current live at, so it should show
Berlin, right now, if you tried.
And that's really nice, you adopt have to
pick that from a list or anything, jousted
get it for free.
Another aspect when developing for mobile
is of course per to mans and battery drain.
So, you want to have fast beautiful graphics,
of course, but you also want to be careful
that you're not actually draining the battery
in the process, so there are a couple of graphics
technologies that you might want to use, so
SVG, I already mentioned that it's vector
based, it's DOM integration, tie certain events
to elements, but it's somewhat slower than
other alternatives I would say.
Faster is canvas, which just gives you a plain
canvas and you can draw on that.
But, kind of a down side is that it's very
low level, so you actually is trough draw
on your canvas, you don't just say, okay,
here's a rectangle and it's going to stay
there, you have to draw it every time.
You also don't get a DOM, you have to figure
out where the user now tapped.
It's kind of the same with webGL, which is
probably faster than Canvas and able to do
D, which is awesome, but, again (3 D) it's
low level, it has no DOM, so basically, pick
your poison.
By now web GM is supported inment iOS 8, so
it's viable to use that.
All right, when we talk about interaction
on mobile devices the main problem is probably
the fat finger problem, which means that you're
using those things here to interact with interact
with anything on your smartphone, most smartphone
company recommend minimum size for on screen
elements, apple says 44 by 44 fix els, but,
yeah, it (Pixels) it varies, but it's always
something in that range.
You have to make sure all your interactive
elements are big enough so people can interact
with them.
Sometimes you can avoid the fat finger problem
all together.
So in the Selfie city project that I did with
Manovich, Stefner and a couple of other amazing
people.
We looked t a the differences in Selfie taking
practices across cities worldwide.
And part of the project was self exploratory
that you can see here, where you can explore
the data set, you have filters at the top
where you can tilter the Selfie collection
based on head orientations, based on glass,
smiles, city and age and stuff like that.
Then you get the results at bottom.
And what was good for us was that everything
was big enough that you could just use it
on your finger so it kind of‑‑ with
your finger so it worked out of the box.
But, of course, the problem is what do you
do when you want to show really high resolution
visualizations that are still interactive.
And again there, are a couple of tricks that
you can use.
Probably the most common trick is invisible
touch areas.
So the idea here is that we have to scatter
part and we want to have people being able
to tap on the circles, and of course they're
much too small, so we create those not very
invisible here, circles, the orange ones,
so mostly you just set the opacity to zero,
give them a high Z index so they're on top
of everything, and made osituation absolute
and stuff like that, you add your touch event
listener and then, of course, those s have
to know which part of the data they represent.
And based on that, you can then have those
things be interactive without actually displaying
them.
But, of course, as you can see, it doesn't
always work, even here in this very simple
example we have this overlap between two circles,
what happens more often is that you just create
a full rectangle, another invisible reck tank
opacity zero, put it on top of your graph
and then every time you have a touch vent
you try to figure out, okay, which part of
the data is the finger closest too or something.
And then I show the tool tip or filter or
whatever.
And talking about tool tips is one of the
main problems when it comes to touch‑based
visualizations, because as I said, we no longer
have hovering really with fingers, but tool
tips are really ubiquitous in visualizations,
they're pretty much in everything because
it's such a nice solution to display details
on demand by showing a little tool tip.
And, in mobile Safari for example we kind
of have hovering, but it's weird and you probably
already seen that, so if you tap on an element
that has some mouse over event defined once,
it triggers the mouse over event and then
when you tap again it's a mouse down.
And for most people that is just totally confusing
because they tapped on something and then
the tool tip pops up and they're not really
sure are they able to tap again or not.
So I can't really recommend that.
A better solution is to have always on tool
tip, always visible but tied to some type
of interaction, in this example from the New
York Times for example, we have two solutions,
first we have a little tool tip there that's
tied to the slider and you can just move that
around.
And you also have here this banner like thing
at the bottom that's always visible and shows
you information.
So that's‑‑ I would say that's probably
a good solution to have something like that.
Then of course you don't only have down sides
you can do ahassing things with multi‑touch
indigestual interactions, so one idea‑‑
gestureal interactions, one idea is to keep
it on one side and decide what to do with
it.
Rotation scaling.
Frameworks can help you, two examples from
the three, and those handle multi‑touch
automatically so if you open them on your
tablet for example, you can pinch to zoom
this world map and you can move multiple circles
around using multiple fingers, if you want
to be more fancy about that, you probably
want the use some gesture library like codeJ
or hammer J several, those detect full gestures
so you get stuff like swiping, pinching, rotating
and long press and so on.
So you can go totally craze crazy with that.
And if you're building something with touch
first in mind, then you can kind of look at
your visualization as something that's deformidable,
some physical object that you can play around
with, that's what I try to do in this research
project here.
‑‑ which isn't playing.
Here we go, that's touch wave.
In touch wave we had a screen graph you could
just manipulate it using your fingers, as
you can see you can just stretch it, enlarge
it, double tap to change the layout, so we
went as far with the metaphor as we thought
useful.
And if you really want to do that, so, that
project is already two years old, so I had
to implement it natively.
But, by now it should probably even work on
the web.
Okay, here we go.
All right, something 245 you can do right
now is you can use, for example, the device
orientation events, which is really cool,
so those actually give you the orientation
of the device in space we've already heard
about‑‑ talked about that yesterday,
which is really neat.
So you can use that for example to build one
of those little demos here, you can check
it out on your smartphone, you this little
globe, when you orient your device in a certain
way, then it spins around, which is a neat
effect, you can probably do all kinds of crazy
things when it comes to visualization, 3 D
maybe even though that's somewhat of a four
letter word in the community.
Yeah, you can build that right in your browser.
That's it for me, here are links to some example,
on my web site as well.
Talk to me on Twitter, send me an e‑mail,
or talk to me later in person.
Thank you.
(Applause)